[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
do you know how many animals I have now
no that's also a following four dogs
nice and three cats nice they're in my
freezer I'm gonna have a barbecue
I love the delicious
they're delicious is that just craft
it's American cheese and I found it on a
Smash Burger these are the best they
melt so [__] good okay just like you
they're single
and yellow
[Laughter]
you know what you are you're like the
stuff they put in those stress balls
whatever's in there that's what you are
yeah what's your name again with the bad
friend shirt so we can call him out for
being a uh this guy right here poser not
a fan poser yeah you know who he's a fan
of who Michael oh hilarious he doesn't
know who that is yeah what's your name
AJ he didn't sign up to be made fun of
by the way oh I'm so sorry so say sorry
sorry I attacked you for no reason I
apologize are you an American citizen so
am I we have something in common well
what I'm barely yeah yeah I'm gonna get
my car next week where are you from AJ
um
he brings these look at he brings these
kids here can I ask you something yeah
do you make them come or do you go hey
um
do you guys want to come awful way to
ask these questions do you make these
kids
there's got to be a million ways right
do you beat these kids
um no don't start with that wait yeah
wait do you oh how about this I got it
right do you make these young adults
come
on right yeah
what do you think the funniest way you
could die is
why this fantasy I want I want my death
to be a mystery
right so no one can solve it okay so I
want to disappear
all right and then one day in New York
they find my arm wrapped up okay and
what just like in like you know I don't
know it's brown packaging you know I
mean like a brown paper bag like a paper
bag right oil stains on the bottom of it
right and there's like a string tying it
together right it's cloudy and moist
right and you know maybe this arm right
so they know that it's me yeah yeah okay
and I want them to find my leg right in
Albuquerque
I wanted them to find my ass part okay
in Mexico City from my waist down like
your penis yeah just okay Mexico City
all right I want them to find every body
part around the world or around the
country at least right okay and have
people go what the [__] happened and
then have people like it'll be like a
thing where people are gonna try to
solve it okay right for the lover no
right so that's the kind of death I want
that's a great answer yeah but I I feel
like the moment when I'm being chopped
up will be horrifying yeah
or I want them to find me in like maybe
in a cow inside a cow yeah like a dead
cow and I'm like fully in it we called
him on the podcast about naming a
sandwich oh yeah that's right I forgot
yeah after you oh that's what they did
they didn't though
the only people I named anything after
were my parents okay if you didn't name
a sandwich what would be in it it was
probably lay huh and be racist I don't
care give us the full just be real be
real if you were forced to make the
Bobby Lee sandwich what would be in it
come
oh what type of bread what kind of bread
all right so what kind of it's a cup of
coffee
if they were doing a Happy Days remake
right and
out of all the Asian actors in your mind
right that could do it who would you be
who would be number one on your [__]
wish list
um anyone from crazy Rich Asians
were you in that they wouldn't see me oh
why is that I'm not Chinese okay Korean
I know but then they said I'm not
Chinese and then I see the [__] movie
guess who's in it who Ken Jung he's
Korean is he really yeah so they [__]
me do you know Kim Jong have you guys
ever I I know Kim Jong-un
I don't know Ken Jong because they can't
get meat in North Korea and there's so
many orphans in the street I don't even
know because if you Google it I can't
find anything because there's no
pictures or anything yeah yeah so this
is what he told me he goes so he goes
there's so many orphans on the street
and they get Hunted
for their meat oh my God right so it's
like you know I wanted to do like a
little like uh Annie but North Korean
version
right and then you if you did any North
Korean version you would not have to
cast a bunch of kids just have Annie
running for her life yeah that's it you
think the rest of the orphans are in
people's bellies yeah right but you
still have the same songs you know what
I mean yeah yeah tomato tomato
hopefully I'll be alive tomorrow
now have you been to Korea before
people
that's what I heard bro
that kind of sounded like a like a Jimmy
Fallon Question yeah yeah and then no no
have you ever been to curl now your
people have you ever gone and seen would
you ever go to like a sex um um you know
they have these things called Hedonism
do you know what that is like a
campedonism yeah would you ever go to
one of those where it's like a vacation
I would [__] party I would you would
yeah yeah why don't we why don't we do
it let's set you up sign me up but is
there a catalog of what they look like
or not you don't know oh you don't know
Rochambeau yeah it's like it's a lottery
scramble you're getting what you get
right and then you do you have to make
love
I think it's hard to show up and like
eat things look up Hedonism and see how
much it is we can get Bobby over to
Hedonism can we get you to do that do
you think would you go on a little trip
yeah if let's zoom in on that question
zoom in on his dick yeah zoom on the
deck I gotta tell you something yeah
yeah pinch and spread Pete Triumph I
gotta tell you that's that's no bigger
than yours buddy mine that's not bigger
than yours it's not no so I'm saying
shouldn't you feel comfortable now
I know but he's going to want to [__]
collaborate so he's gonna go hey would
you follow me on this and then let's do
videos together and the next thing I do
I'm doing sketches with this guy in the
[__] tree only fans yeah I don't want
to do that you know me I can't say no I
know in that environment so I'm going oh
yeah oh I'm writing sketches
right and then can my girlfriend do it
right and then they're [__] I'm not
[__] anybody and I'm like the head
writer of their [__] Hedonism
schedule yeah I don't want to do that do
you remember having a Bobby got stuck in
a girl Jamaica he's doing like sketches
now yeah full time he's a showrunner in
[__] so during the Vietnam war right
um these Vietnamese monks you know if
he's in the photos no in protest they
would um advertise in newspapers that
they're a monk is going to light himself
on fire so he would sit Indian style and
put gasoline on him and he would sit
that way light himself on fire not move
and die out of protest oh my God you
were thinking you'd be like ah you're
right right but he would sit there in
that Indian style
right and it's like so is it that
painful or is that guy just [__] that
guy's proving a point
that's not insane that status Mind Over
Matter even if I was like I have to
prove this right I have this to Indian
style I don't think I would be like that
way no I'd be running toward a leg
the people that are in the movie are
fancy right yeah so so I so I show up
I'm in the hotel and on the bed there's
a letter and it said dear Bobby welcome
to the movie I'm so excited to work with
you meet me downstairs tomorrow at noon
and it said um Jamie Lee Curtis
yes insane right
and I go holy [__] so I'm like all day
long I'm like looking in the mirror
trying to like you know what I mean look
proper like Hollywood
no you're just did you suck in your
cheeks I'm just trying to look like cool
you know what I mean yes all right and I
show up so I showed their noon the next
day she's super sweet like one of the
nicest people you'll ever meet and there
was but then there was other people so
she had written notes to everybody so
there was a Penn and Teller pan from
Penn and Teller which he was in the
movie great guy one of the best
magicians of all time yes and then there
was another handsome actor by the name
of Cheyenne Jackson okay he's like yeah
you know he is super talented handsome
super nice right hot as [__] and I was
looking at him I was like and he's gay
so I was like I can't suck his date but
my point and he's also Mary had kids and
I'm also I'm not gay I don't know why I
just said that but my point is is that
and Jamie goes um
we're gonna go I want to show you
something historical
so I'm like just keep your shirt just
you're fine you know what I mean I don't
say anything you know I'm just kind of
like a Christian
was that good yeah yeah so we walked to
this River
right yeah and along the river there's
like these bronze shoes
bronze bronze shoes
hundreds of pairs like on the side of
the river
like look shoes right and she goes no no
you don't get it she goes during the
Holocaust times you know I mean Hitler
came in here lined up all these people
along this River shot him in their head
and the Jews and they threw them in the
river right and it's it's somber right
yes
so they look cute yeah yeah so then
Cheyenne Jackson goes oh no
he goes
look
a little kid's shoes oh no right and
everyone looks at it right and there's
these tiny little brown shoes there
right and I yell out
it could have been a [__] I had a
medical emergency when
I played ping pong oh
I don't get any more stereotypes I know
right the way I said I play
[Laughter]
um
I play ping pong and then um
the next day I looked on my thigh and my
nut sack
and there was like a pirate Scar from my
pubes down to my anus what it was weird
it was like
somebody had sticks stabbing with a
knife like no let's just cut me what was
it well then I don't know
so then I just it's still there what no
it was there but then it turned into
something else
so then I put antibiotic cream that
kalala had yeah on it and then a couple
days later
it was this purple bumpy itchy rash that
went from you know my thigh here all the
way down to my [__] Sac regions Jesus
it was bumps I did [__]
okay after it evolved it evolved
that caterpillar turned into a butterfly
and I went to the Dr kawashiri is my
doctor
he's the best doctor I've ever had
he goes what's the matter I go I told
him he goes put it down so I pulled down
my pants and
he looked at it he goes oh that's common
jock itch so he brought me that's what
sockets looks like yeah he goes I know
what to use yeah and then he goes no
turn around
I go why because I gotta look at your
butthole but
but what he didn't realize is that I had
taken a [__] oh 30 minutes before he's
listening 30 minutes before and it was
in such a rush I didn't clean it all the
way so this is what Dr kawashiri did
bend over I bend over it he opened it
and then he closed it he put He
collected this stuff and he just left
he didn't say goodbye or anything he
didn't write you a prescription no when
I went out I go he just left and they're
like oh yeah he this is the prescription
you need
he was disgusting with you he saw
something so no he just it did this
closed it
I don't even say he said goodbye you
just laughed he had to close the ass
while she opened it like she just open
it that's it it kind of comes back no no
my butt nobody's like Play-Doh you have
to put it back
our asses automatically okay it doesn't
have that elastic but it will stay open
it stays open
I refuse to compromise
no more oh we it you know we ate steak
last night let's go to this vegan place
before it's like okay I'll eat that not
anymore have fun I'm going to Morton's
again
that's where I'm at now yep you mean oh
um hey we saw that scary movie last
night let's watch this [__] romantic
no [__] yourself I'm watching the scary
movie again
I'm no I'm not doing any of it go to my
friend's wedding go [__] yourself I'm
not going brunch I'll do that okay I'll
do brunch
foreign
[Music]